trauerfeier für prinz philip die
britische königsfamilie nimmt abschied
vom ehemann der queen auf schloss
windsor beigesetzt umstrittene
bundesweite notbremse einige
landesregierungen setzen die
ausgangssperren jetzt darum andere
zögern und fordern nachbesserungen und
hansi flick will gehen der trainer von
rekordmeister bayern münchen bittet um
die auflösung seines vertrags
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zum nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
samstag polizei ist auch dabei für den
sport sehr gerne hallo schön plant eine
trauerfeier wegen corona im engsten
familienkreis das geld heute auch für
die britische königsfamilie
keiner hat die queen enger und länger
begleitet als ihr mit 99 jahren
verstorbener mann ein vorbild an treue
pflichtbewusstsein und ritterlichkeit
hieß es in der kirche zum abschied ließ
die queen dieses foto veröffentlichen
das paar lächelnd geradezu gelöst im
gras eines schottischen nationalparks
2003 war das er war meine stärke und
meine stütze in all den jahren so
elisabeth einmal über ihren mann mehr
als 70 jahre waren sie verheiratet
auf schloss windsor wurde prinz philip
nun beigesetzt
allein er hatte sich eine kleine und
bescheidene zeremonie gewünscht heißt es
auch aufgrund der pandemie beschränkung
ist es genau dazu gekommen was
keineswegs bedeutet dass die beisetzung
prinz philip heute auf schloss windsor
nicht wie im britischen königshaus
üblich äußerst stilvoll und mit allen
militärischen ehren von statten ging um
kurz vor 15 uhr ortszeit wurde der sarg
mit philips leichnam auf einem nach
seinen vorstellungen umgebauten land
rover aufgebahrt dahinter die vier
kinder des herzogs von edinburgh und die
drei männlichen enkel
den jüngsten familiären verwicklungen
war es geschuldet dass die windsors zwei
orten aber keine uniformen trugen
zwischen denen sich in streit
befindlichen brüdern william und harry
prinzessin enstone peter philips die
kurze prozession führte vom staats
eingang des schlosses zur st georgs
kapelle
die königin war im bentley
vorausgefahren ganz allein wurde sie vom
erzbischof von canterbury in empfang
genommen
im blumenkranz auf den sarg von ihr ein
persönlicher gruß an ihren ehemann über
73 jahre dazu prinz philips marine mütze
und sein schwert um punkt 15 uhr dann
eine schweigeminute im ganzen land auch
den großen monitoren auf londons
piccadilly circus bilder aus dem leben
des herzogs auch die musik während des
gottesdienstes hatte der verstorbene
selbst ausgewählt der dekan von windsor
und der erzbischof sprachen dann wurde
der sarg hinunter in die gruft der
kapelle gelassen
ein moment der familiären intimität der
in der übertragung pietätvoll mit diesem
gang eines dudelsack pfeiffers
repräsentiert wurde der herzog ist tot
und beigesetzt
das augenmerk und alles mitgefühl der
nation gilt nun der königin
diana zimmermann in windsor hat dieser
abschied von prinz philip das land
wieder mehr zusammengebracht
es gab schon durchaus sehr
unterschiedliche reaktion auf den tod
von von prinz philip man darf nicht
vergessen hier sind im vergangenen jahr
130.000 menschen an cholera gestorben
und fanden so einige dass selbst die
abgespeckte zeremonie heute doch noch
relativ viel tamtam war dafür dass das
leben eines 99 jährigen zu ende gegangen
ist viele briten konnten im vergangen
jahr überhaupt keinen abschied nehmen
von ihren verstorbenen verwandten die
bisher eine rekord flut von beschwerden
bekommen nachdem sie am vergangenen
wochenende über fast nichts anderes mehr
berichtet hat
andere wiederum haben diesen anlass
genutzt um über das jahrhundert phillips
und ihr eigenes leben nachzudenken die
wenigsten können sich natürlich
überhaupt nur noch daran erinnern wie es
war als philip noch keine rolle in
großbritannien spielte und am ehesten
kommen die briten zusammen in ihrer
sorge um die queen die wird nächste
woche zehn jahre alt und natürlich ist
es so dass sie jetzt eine trauernde ist
etwas das ihr in diesem jahr besonders
viele menschen nach führen können danke
schön nach wien zur einschätzung von
diana zimmermann zur corona pandemie und
den aktuellen infektionszahlen die
weiter sorgen bereiten die
gesundheitsämter meldeten dem
robert-koch-institut 23.800 vier neue
fälle knapp 300 weniger als vergangenen
samstag 219 menschen starben in
verbindung mit dem virus
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
steigt auf 160,7 die kritik von unions
politikern an der geplanten bundesweiten
notbremse zur eindämmung der korona
pandemie reißt nicht ab
hessens ministerpräsident bouffier
bezweifelt in der bild zeitung dass die
ausgangs beschränkungen im neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz rechtlich
zulässig sind
brandenburg und mecklenburg vorpommern
führen ab montag eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre 1 tobias häfner fasst
zusammen noch mal eine hose kaufen
schmuck oder spielzeug im kröpeliner tor
center sind viele rostocker unterwegs
bevor ab montag wieder alles dicht macht
schafe krone regeln können die meisten
hier verstehen das hin und her im alltag
weniger es ist schon verständlich dass
man vorsichtig ist aber nach diesem paar
also immer ein paar wochen auf dann
wieder zu irgendwann reicht's auch die
ladenbesitzer sehen ihre branche nicht
als pandemie treiber die pandemie aber
immer mehr als einen weg in echte
wirtschaftliche not was wir und was die
besucher nicht verstehen können was den
unterschied macht im handel zwischen
einem drogeriemarkt und einem
spielwarengeschäft die jetzigen schritte
belastend aber unvermeidbar sei
die landesregierung niedrige instanzen
geringe belastung dann gibt es öffnungen
und hohe instanzen hohe belastungen der
krankenhäuser
dann müssen wir auch zu schließungen
kommen alles ausrichten nach den zahlen
dieses politische konzept halten nicht
alle für sinnvoll
nach 14 monaten in der pandemie kann ein
modernes land wie deutschland das sich
auf die fahnen schreibt auch
technologisch vorne zu sein doch nicht
auf alternativen verzichten auf kontakt
nach verfolgungen per app etwa oder
regelmäßiges testen mit nachweisen die
digital geliefert werden können
egal wie schnelleres handeln sei nötig
meinen experten
zeit ist das was wir am wenigsten bei
dieser pandemie haben jeden tag den wir
länger warten um beschlüsse umzusetzen
und dann wirklich verbindlich zu machen
verlieren wir wertvolle zeit in der
millionenstadt köln heute abend erstmals
volle ausgangssperre ab 21 uhr
nicht jeder versteht wer trifft sich
abends zu können ganz raus die behörden
setzen jedenfalls auf eine nacht mit
weniger kontakten trotz verbots haben
sich in stuttgart heute hunderte gegner
der korona maßnahmen versammelt die
meisten ohne maske und ohne abstände
einzuhalten
obwohl die zwei demos untersagt waren
hatte die sogenannte querdenken bewegung
zur teilnahme aufgerufen
die polizei stoppte die versammlung und
nahm hunderte menschen in gewahrsam
auch in dresden kamen demonstranten
zusammen und versuchten in die
innenstadt zu gelangen polizisten
erteilten platzverweise
die jugendämter in deutschland erwarten
dass die zahl der schulabbrecher wegen
der korona pandemie weiter sehr hoch
bleibt im vergangenen jahr hatten
210.000 schule vorzeitig die schule
verlassen mehr als doppelt so viele wie
vor der pandemie diese entwicklung werde
sich fortsetzen und durch viele
bevölkerungsschichten ziehen heißt es in
einem bericht der zeitungen der funke
mediengruppe die union ringt weiter um
ihren kanzlerkandidaten bis morgen
wollen sich armin laschet und markus
söder einigen noch lässt keiner von
beiden ein zeichen des verzichts
erkennen
allerdings mehren sich die drängenden
stimmen sachsens ministerpräsident
kretschmann zum beispiel fordert eine
zügige entscheidung in stunden dass die
kandidatenfrage auch sehr viel
geräuschloser zu lösen ist zeigen gerade
die grünen in umfragen seit langem
zweitstärkste partei hinter der union
am montag wollen die parteichefs
entscheiden wer von ihnen beiden ins
rennen ums kanzleramt annalena baerbock
oder robert habeck beide stellten sich
heute den fragen bei landes und
kreisverbänden die 40 jährige studierte
völkerrechtlerin in brandenburg der 51
jährige schriftsteller in schleswig
holstein
das besagt berichtet robert habeck lässt
sich auf der grünen wiese für den
bundestag nominieren
der ort ist corona bedingt bescheiden
der anspruch des parteivorsitzenden ist
es nicht ich will die grünen in die
regierung führen deutschland ist zu
lange schon nicht durch die grünen
regiert worden und das war nicht gut für
dieses land das muss sich jetzt ändern
das wollen wir ändern
zum ersten mal in ihrer geschichte
kämpfen die grünen um platz eins bei der
bundestagswahl
sie wollen ins kanzleramt dafür treten
wir dafür trete ich im september an für
eine erneuerung unseres landes noch
haben berbalk und habe ich nicht erklärt
wer kanzlerkandidat wird vor jahren noch
hätte eine solche hinterzimmer
entscheidung den unmut der basis
provoziert heute gehört geschlossenheit
offenbar zur grünen parteifreunde auf
montag und wünscht braucht auf die
beiden machen im vergleich zu
es ist diese geschlossen heute die es
auch ermöglichen soll
das anders als bei anderen parteien der
unterlegene nicht als verlierer dasteht
unabhängig davon also wer einen halben
schritt zurück geht und wer dann diese
kandidatur übernimmt werde ich teil des
spitzenteams in berlin sein und einen
bundespolitischen wahlkampf führen
sie werden gemeint
diesem wahlkampf auch im team und
gemeinsam mit unserer parteien gern zu
führen am montag wollen die beiden
parteivorsitzenden bekanntgeben wer
kanzlerkandidat oder kandidatin wird
noch mal zurück zur union cdu chef zu
werden dass es dem ehemaligen
unions-fraktionsvorsitzenden friedrich
merz bislang trotz zweier versuche nicht
gelungen aber der 65-jährige will zurück
in den bundestag heute wählte ihn der
kreisverband des hochsauerlandkreises zu
seinem direktkandidaten und bekam vom
märz direkt zu hören was ihn ausfüllt
die cdu habe ihren kompass verloren
die wahl fand übrigens corona bedingt im
sport stadium in arnsberg statt
programms
blumen für friedrich merz gegen den
aktuellen cdu abgeordneten patrick
sensburg setzt märz sich in einer
kampfabstimmung durch in seiner rede
hatte er auf den schlechten zustand
seiner partei hingewiesen
die cdu hat ihren kompass verloren
unsere wählerinnen und wähler soweit
noch vorhanden wissen nicht mehr wofür
wir eigentlich stehen wir verlieren an
die grünen vor allem im westen auch hier
im hochsauerlandkreis weiter an die afd
vor allem im osten patrick sensburg war
friedrich merz im jahr 2009 als
abgeordneter für das hochsauerland nach
gefolgt und hat sich seitdem im
bundestag einen namen gemacht er
verweist auf seine rolle in berlin
ich möchte ihnen aber auch sagen dass
ich in berlin gut vernetzt bin ich bin
vorsitzender des sogenannten ersten
ausschuss ist das ist der ausschuss für
wahlprüfung immunität und
geschäftsordnung ich bin mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss mitglied im
ältestenrat sensburg erhielt 126 stimmen
friedrich merz dagegen 327 erleichterung
beim ehemaligen fraktionsvorsitzenden
tut ganz gut mal wieder eine abstimmung
zu gewinnen
gute aussichten also für friedrich merz
dem bundestag bald wieder anzugehören
zumindest diese personalie hat die union
geklärt die usa besinnen sich bei ihrem
harten außenpolitischen kurs gegen china
auf alte allianzen
das wurde besonders deutlich beim
treffen des japanischen premiers sogar
mit us-präsident beiden mit sorge sehen
beide wie china seine gebietsansprüche
im pazifik ausweitet vor allem im
südchinesischen meer aber auch auf
inseln im ostchinesischen meer die auch
japan für sich reklamiert und nicht
zuletzt auf taiwan das peking als teil
der volksrepublik sieht elmar theveßen
besuch aus asien ein signal welche
regionen der welt dem neuen mann im
weißen haus derzeit wohl die wichtigste
ist japans premierminister sogar der
erste regierungsbehörden reden sich mit
vornamen an yoshi und so vereint in
sorge beide sehen in den militärischen
muskelspielen china ist die größte
bedrohung für den frieden im
indopazifischen raum
wir werden unsere gemeinsamen werte
entschlossen verteidigen und
voranbringen einschließlich
menschenrechte und rechtsstaatlichkeit
wir werden auf jeden versuch unterbinden
den status quo im ost und
südchinesischen meer durch gewalt
erpressung oder einschüchterung zu
verändern beiden und zugabe sprachen
beim arbeitstreffen china auch den
dialog anzubieten beim kampf gegen den
klimawandel im umgang mit nordkoreas
diktator kim die usa und japan wollen
sehr eng bei technologischen
entwicklungen zusammen arbeiten beim 5g
mobilfunk bei künstlicher intelligenz
und diese technologien richten sich dann
nach den gemeinsamen demokratischen
normen gesetzt von demokratien nicht
autokratie sogar wurde gefragt ob die
olympischen spiele in tokio trotz der
pandemie wirklich stattfinden präsident
biden hat seine unterstützung
signalisiert japan durch mit aller
sorgfalt die vorbereitungen für die
spiele fortsetzen und die impfstoffe
allen teilnehmern zugänglich machen
amerika erneuert seine bündnisse in
asien bald empfänger beiden hier auch
den präsidenten von südkorea auf kuba
geht an diesem wochenende eine ära zu
ende
mehr als 60 jahre lang lenkte ein castro
die tonangebende kommunistische ein harz
partei nun tritt der 89 jährige bruder
des verstorbenen revolutionsführers
fidel castro zurück übermorgen soll
miguel diaz kanal zum neuen parteichef
gewählt werden
er hatte vor drei jahren schon das
präsidentenamt von raul castro
übernommen
und jetzt noch ins all bzw zu einer
rückkehr aus dem all mit einer
sojus-kapsel sind drei raumfahrer sicher
auf der erde gelandet
eine us-amerikanerin und zwei russische
kollegen ein halbes jahr waren die drei
an bord der iss rund 400 kilometer über
der erde hatten sie zahlreiche
experimente durchgeführt
auch schön wieder zu hause zu sein denke
ich
und jetzt zur sportlichen nachricht des
tages die kommt aus münchen ja wichtige
personalie bayern münchens trainer hansi
flick hat den deutschen fußball
rekordmeister um auflösung seines
vertrags gebeten zum ende der saison
soll schluss sein
damit wäre auch der weg für ihn frei um
als bundestrainer die nachfolge von
joachim löw anzutreten
nach dem ausscheiden in der champions
league am dienstag hatte hansi flick
erstmals abwanderungs gerüchte befeuert
dass ich mir gedanken machen über meine
zukunft
ich glaube dass da hat jeder von ihnen
auch verständnis er habe den fc bayern
und seine mannschaft vor dem heutigen
spiel in wolfsburg darüber informiert
dass er sein bis 2023 laufenden vertrag
frühzeitig auflösen möchte
der 56 jährige gilt damit als heißer
anwärter auf den bundestrainer posten
betont aber dass es noch keine gespräche
gegeben habe als co trainer hatte er mit
joachim löw 2014 den wm-titel geholt und
war danach sportdirektor beim dfb jetzt
zur wahrheit auf dem platz bayern
münchen bleibt voll auf
meisterschaftskurs 29 da spielt hat in
der fußball bundesliga hier sind die
samstags ergebnisse im spitzenspiel
gewinnen die bayern beim tabellendritten
wolfsburg mit 3 zu 2
dämpfer für eintracht frankfurt gladbach
siegt deutlich mit 4 0
schalke kassierte ein 0 4 in freiburg
union berlin vfb stuttgart 21 keine tore
bei augsburg bielefeld das abendspiel
leverkusen gegen köln dann ausführlich
im sportstudio gestern leipzig
hoffenheim null zu null in der tabelle
enteilen die bayern der konkurrenz
sieben-punkte-vorsprung vor leipzig
keiner veränderung bis platz sechs wobei
dortmund und leverkusen noch spielen
müssen gladbach siebter punktgleich
dahinter union berlin
die zweite tabellenhälfte beginnt jetzt
mit stuttgart hertha hat erstmal corona
zwangspause rutscht auf 16 abgeschlagen
letzter hinter dem ersten fc köln
schalke 04
ja wie gesagt ausführlich der spielzeit
wie gewohnt nachher im aktuellen
sportstudio zu gast paderborns trainer
steffen baumgart das final four turnier
um den deutschen basketball pokal in
münchen ist nach zwei corona fällen im
göttinger team für dieses wochenende
abgesagt worden
das hat die basketball bundesliga mit
dem gesundheitsamt münchen entschieden
und formel 1 pilot sebastian vettel
enttäuscht im qualifying von ihm mit
startplatz 13 lewis hamilton jubelt über
die 99 pole position
der formel 1 weltmeister geht morgen vom
besten startplatz ins zweite
saisonrennen preis überraschend kommt
für lewis hamilton offenbar die 99 pole
position seiner karriere
der mercedes pilot auf dem relativ
schmalen kurs seinen rivalen max
verstappen knapp in schach
der niederländer sogar nur dritter
hinter seinem stallgefährten paris
überzeugend neuling mit schumacher als
achtzehnter angesichts seines
unterlegenen autos sebastian vettel
enttäuscht als dreizehnter weit entfernt
von den podiumskandidaten das war der
sport am samstag fielen akuten gerne
der sonntag wird trüb etwas milder und
auch ein wenig nass ob die kommende
woche frühlingshafter wird weiß gleich
katja horneffer das heute journal gegen
viertel vor elf mit marietta slomka und
wir sind morgen wieder da schön dass sie
dabei waren wir wünschen ihnen alles
gute und noch ein unbeschwertes
wochenende auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren so
sonnig wie es heute zum beispiel im
westen deutschlands noch mal war ist es
morgen eigentlich nur noch am meer
höchsttemperaturen von 15 grad gibt es
morgen nicht nur in moskau sondern auch
in helsinki in warschau in oslo in
london in paris und auch in galicien bei
uns in deutschland wird allerdings nicht
besonders viel milder
denn die luft die davon nordosten
herankommt zwischen dem hoch über
skandinavien und den tiefer im schwarzen
meer ist doch vor allen dingen feucht
bringt also auch regen mit andere teams
nehmen reißaus entweder über das
mittelmeer oder über das nordmeer
heute nacht ist es also meist bedeckt
und es fällt etwas regen an den alpen
auch schneeregen die nacht deutlich
milder als die vergangenen nur noch
zwischen dem thüringer wald und am
alpenrand droht bodenfrost sonst werkes
bei 6 bis 3 grad milder und morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 6
grad an den alpen und 15 grad in der
uckermark und der vormittags meist
bedeckt einzig an den küsten von nord
und ost und dem emsland sehen sie die
sonne noch länger es sind schon einige
schauer unterwegs an den alpen auch
schneeregenschauer und nachmittags gibt
es dann sogar einige gewitter in der
neuen woche geht es doch sehr
unbeständig weiter es wird aber von tag
zu tag ein bisschen milder mit elf bis
18 grad am mittwoch schönes wochenende